allard au rendez vous pour les
agriculteurs merci la parole étant
monsieur charles de la verpillière
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre votre gouvernement a le
devoir d'assurer l'équilibré et la
justice entre tous les territoires de
france vous ne le faites pas vous
favorisez trop souvent paris et lyon au
détriment des communes périphériques
ainsi vous autorisez madame hidalgo à
fermer les voies sur berge à paris alors
que les reports de trafic vont asphyxier
les communes à l'est de paris
et maintenant vous allez faire le même
cadeau à lyon avec les mêmes
conséquences sans aucune concertation
avec les départements voisins
en effet vous allez déclasser les
autoroutes a6 et a7 qui traverse
l'agglomération lyonnaise pour permettre
à monsieur gérard collomb d'en faire un
boulevard urbain ou le transit des poids
lourds sera interdite dès 2017
seize mille véhicules par jour vont donc
se reporter à l'est de lyon sur les
autoroutes à 46 et à 432 dans le
département de l'ain ces autoroutes sont
déjà saturés ou sur le point de l'être
elles ne pourront pas absorber ce trafic
supplémentaire d'autant plus que les
autres itinéraires de contournement ne
seront pas réalisés avant 2030 voire
par exemple le bouclage du périphérique
lyonnais par l'anneau des sciences est
très hypothétique
monsieur le premier ministre les
habitants de l'ain en ont assez de
supporter les nuisances bruit pollution
bouchons dont lyon ne veut plus nous
ressentons une profonde injustice
allez vous monsieur le premier ministre
jouez votre rôle d'arbitré pour que l'un
ne soient plus victimes
de l'égoïsme et de l'impérialisme
lyonnais merci la parole et à monsieur
alain vidalies secrétaire d'état chargé
des transports de la mer et de la pêche
oui merci monsieur le président monsieur
le député vous l'avez reconnue vous même
la situation de lyon et de la si ces
deux là cet est une situation singulière
en france c'est une situation que le
résultat de l'histoire on ne va pas la
juger aujourd'hui mais dans une
métropole dans une grande ville comme
lyon avoir une autoroute qui passe au
milieu de la ville et qui entraîne des
nuisances sonores qui polluent et qui
empêche tout développement urbain s'il
n'y a pas aujourd'hui en france d'autres
situations et lorsque le président de
lyon et le président de la communauté
d'agglomération de la métropole sont
venus nous exposer le problème
je crois que quand on regarde
objectivement la situation
ça ne peut pas durer comme ça et
effectivement au nom du gouvernement
donné mon autorisation pour le
déclassement de l'autoroute pour que ça
devienne un aménagement urbain et je
crois que quand on regarde objectivement
la situation
c'est la seule réponse que l'on peut
apporter à des élus à des populations
qui vivent une situation qui n'a pas de
pareil en france et qui obère le
développement et le vivre ensemble et
aussi la protection de l'environnement
dans ces conditions je vous confirme que
le gouvernement est favorable à cette
mesure de déclassement que j'ai annoncé
que j'ai demandé au préfet de mettre en
place un groupe de travail d'associer
l'ensemble des élus pour bien évidemment
examiné les conséquences et vous avez
raison la question est légitime
je veux simplement rappeler tu veux
simplement rappeler que l'essentiel du
trafic
bien qu'on soit en collectant urbaine
est intraitable trafic urbain et que le
transit ne représente à partir des
études que nous avons fait que 15 %
c'est ce 15% qu'il peut se reporter
comme vous l'avez posez donc nous
examinons avec les élus et avec
l'ensemble des élus
les mesures compensatoires mais je vous
confirme qu'il faut répondre à la tante
de lyon et de la population
younes pour mettre fin à une situation
anormale merci monsieur le ministre la
séance des questions au gouvernement et